well joining us now from Westminster is
a Labour candidate that who is standing
again David Lammy he's standing in
London but he's not here I don't know
that mr. laning have you been to Labour
Party manifesto launches in the past I
have been to manifesto launches in the
past if I go back to the Tony Blair
period particularly I wish I could be up
there in Bradford I'll certainly get out
of London over the coming weeks I've
been doing a lot of support of
colleagues here in London but I look
forward to knocking on doors in
Yorkshire in the coming weeks now you
make your point by not coming to a
launch under jeremy corbyn's leadership
absolutely not Adam look I'm not
currently on the front bench I'm here
supporting colleagues in London I was in
Hammersmith in Kensington North and
yesterday and hillford north as well so
it's important that people like me get
around the country and I intend to do
that I I look forward to the detail of
course of the manifesto because this is
an exciting moment radical proposals a
serious alternative real investment in
our public services and of course those
who should and can pay more should pay a
bit more and that's also what the
manifesto will say 95% of the country
not paying more but why we've got
corporation tax below 20% in this
country and why indeed we want to not
see those who can make a bigger
contribution on over 80,000 pounds a
year contributing more so we've got
proper public services I think you'll
find that the people of Yorkshire find
this very appealing indeed it's not a
little bit more is it makes a lot more a
9% increase in corporation tax a
surcharge on financial transactions a
surcharge on top salaries plus income
tax
up for people like head teachers and
senior bureaucrats in public service
everybody's paying quite a lot more do
you think that is really good for the
economy given where it is at the moment
given that inflation is going up anyway
well Adam everybody isn't paying a lot
of people watching this show at the
moment they'll be care assistants and
teaching assistants and dinner ladies
their work for local authorities their
work for Primark or Sainsbury's and
actually what they're seeing are serious
cuts to their children's funding at
school they're seeing long waits in a
A&E
they're seeing their salaries stagnated
not rising over the last seven years and
they're also experiencing in their local
communities food banks they're feeling
the squeeze and what they're hearing
from labour if yes if you're on eighty
one hundred thousand plus which is
something that most of your viewers will
simply not recognize can you pay a bit
more and if you're a large corporation
instead of getting away with paying no
tax at all then we're actually going to
go after you and yes our corporation tax
will still be the lowest in the g7 but
actually it was 28% back at the end of a
Labour government
it will now be 26% which is still lower
than it was before we had to crash that
feels fair it will be very interesting
to see if we hear anything from the
Tories matching this but I think viewers
understand you either tax a little bit
more or you get a real squeeze on local
authority NoCal authority spending and a
real squeeze on our public services
people are sick to the back teeth of the
austerity actually people at the top can
pay a bit more and should pay a bit more
thank you David let me this sees all
that politics coming up next I'll be
speaking to the cello Transport Minister
Andy McDonald as we await the launch of
a manifesto here in Bradford
[Music]